Bear was telling me that he did a
Carolines in New York City was like,
it was almost like a college gig.
He's like,
people are so sensitive now in New York.
Oh, you know, he and I just did a,
the VFW hall and Hollywood and, uh,
then,
uh,
the it and I was calling him
about another comic that I wanted.
I was just talking to the bar. I
thought he was really funny. Uh,
and I now can't remember
his name. Uh, Joe Derosa
and I called him and he goes, yeah, I
know. He's really good. And uh, and,
and uh, he goes, how about I
come over and do it? And I'm
like, well, of course, Bill,
whatever you want to do, time
on it. Come on over. Well,
he was doing a bunch of Trump
stuff and, and uh, you know,
and I guarantee you my fans are
pretty split down the middle,
but it did not go over well and he
didn't give a fiddlers fuck about it.
And so he just made him mad and
stirred them up for about 20 minutes.
And then we both, uh, I did my set and
we smoked a cigar and uh, he, you know,
he's not drinking either for like a year.
Yeah. He looks great. He looks really
good. He looks thin and healthy.
Yeah. Yeah. That the Trump
jokes or interesting because uh,
I don't remember anybody getting
mad at you for Bush jokes.
Right. It's different. His jokes,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Even if you were a,
like a Bush supporter,
you could crack a joke about the
way he spells potato or something.
Like nobody gave a fuck. They didn't
care. It was a different thing.
Even if people were supporting and Bush,
by the way, that's spelled potato wrong.
Quail. Quail. That's right. That's right.
That's how these rumors get started,
man is I don't think it's data. You
conspiracy dude over here. It off.
This who spelled potato wrong shit.
Oh, that's right. It was him. Um,
Bush. Fuck some things up
too though. Didn't he? Well,
didn't fuck stuff up.
There's the whole album,
like the wit and wisdom of George W.
Bush. She says like, fool me once.
Shame on you. Shame on
me again. I don't know.
You know what's interesting about Bush
is when he was running for governor of
Texas, he had a completely
different way of communicating.
He talked like a really smart guy. He's
very articulate. I mean he was a smooth,
smooth talker,
like argument.
Wwe does a video of him from back in
the day when he was running for governor
and he's great. You'll listen to
him like glue, this energetic,
intelligent guys articulate.
He seems like one of us and then there's,
they had a side by side video comparing
him to like Bush after seven years in
office, like he's barely hanging
on because I pay attention to shit.
He's given the reins to heaven
and Hell to Dick Cheney.
Dick Cheney is in a bunker, seven miles
underground making the ferries decisions.
You know? I mean it was
weird. It was a weird time,
but you can make fun of Bush all day long.
Nobody gave a fuck.
You make fun of Trump today.
People want to kill.
You got almost got into a scuffle
the other day at the gas station.
This guy just starts spouting out stuff.
He was putting gas in his car right
over there and, and, and just,
and by the first word that you is that
came out of his mouth from nowhere,
hadn't said a word to the guy,
didn't say hi to him. Nothing.
Nancy Polosi is the dumbest person
that ever lived on this planet. And,
and I get baited so easy.
I just said probably not.
Probably not that you're probably wrong,
it's probably not.
Oh, Obama was an idiot. He graduated
number one from Harvard law.
So yeah, views politically
aside, we can start with,
he's probably not stupid.
And what a good speaker.
He was the best. Oh yeah, it
was smooth. Most presidential,
he was a,
he was a guy that you were happy to have
represent you whether you believe with,
you know,
believe in him and support his ideas are
not as a representative of our culture
of our civilization. That guy was
smooth and measured and articulate and,
and off the book, you know it most of
the time, but you know, he was just,
he was saying what he thought and he
wasn't reading off a of scripted, well,
you know the story about
Clinton. I know, I know. Saw,
know with being off the book,
Clinton was such a good orator
that the teleprompter went off.
It broke like five minutes into his
fucking speech and he did all that shit by
memory.
You see the whole goddamn thing by memory.
And I played the nine holes of golf with
him. Was he like, and uh, it was, well,
there's still security secret
service all around him.
And so it was a private golf course.
Uh,
Larry Ellison a that
owns oracle. Oh Wow. Uh,
owns this private golf course.
It has 14, he's a big tennis guy,
so he puts on the tennis stuff out in
palm springs and nobody plays his course
and he doesn't play golf.
And uh,
it's just his privacy as a deal
as own course. Got his, yeah,
he's got his own courses.
He played through our group and
shadow creek and Beverly Hill. I mean,
I'm in Vegas. It really exclusive
course, impossible to get on.
And he was playing by himself and
he was gone the tee box and I said,
as lonely at the top end.
And Larry, he goes, yeah.
And he was balling and went off by himself
and uh, but he wasn't even there but,
but Clinton was,
and he told me a story goes his friend
of his a record producer rap records,
big.
I,
you didn't tell me who it was and didn't
tell me who the artist was either,
but the artists was all thugged out and
he was in a Ferrari store and, and uh,
and uh,
the salesman,
he goes that you thinking about
buying this car and the guy goes, no,
I'm going to buy the car.
I'm thinking about pussy.
So the Clinton told me his story that
had the word pussy in it and Clinton
Clinton told me that that's a great
fucking story.
That is a great story.
That poor bastard.
He's almost like a comic.
Like you could just be free.
Yeah.
If think if he got divorced and just
started going on the honest Bill Clinton
fucked her. Yeah, I did. I didn't
want to either. Going to do,
what would you do? Would you do? You're in
my position. Would you do, you're smart.
You know,
you don't got the 40 years left to live
out a show of lap Prager ride in her
mouth. That's what I love. The whole
idea of being the fucking number one guy.
You gotta be so Goddamn Pussy hungry
to want to be the number one guy,
100% you got to have big appetites
that for sure. For everything. Yeah.
For everything. For everything. Yeah.
That'd be super conqueror. Yeah.
And all those guys aren't seeing,
I'm not all those guys.
I don't want to generalize,
but, but it's really,
really common for men that are in power
positions to just be horny as fuck all
the time. Of course. I
mean, we got to go back.
The way we want these people to behave
is so contrary to the way any king ever
behaved ever in history.
Like the stories of kings
throughout history was always
decadents. It was always,
you know,
all these women and why is food and more
food and feeding them vast open sores
and cutting off the fucking
ex wives heads and shit.
Like that's what you think of ordering
armies, people protecting them.
It's like those people were just gluttons
the super gluttons of the world and we
don't like that.
So then we tried to turn someone into some
fucking Norman Rockwell person. Right?
And that doesn't work either. It's not,
you don't have enough, uh, you don't, you,
you don't have enough charisma to lead.
Maybe, you know, Trump is showing us that,
like, you could talk shit about
him 24, seven, 365 days a year.
He's not adjusting anything.
In fact, he digs his heels in.
He the same fucking guy.